there's a 25 year old social studies
teacher at Crystal River middle school
in Florida who happens to also moonlight
as the host of a white nationalist
podcast called unapologetic her name is
Dianna validity but she's been using the
pseudonym Tiana dalla cough on the
podcast that she hosts and in this
podcast the florida social studies
teacher brags about how she teaches her
white supremacist views in a public
school she rails against diversity in
schools on her podcast she promotes
debunked race IQ conspiracies she brags
about how she has been hiding her white
nationalism from school administrators
and she even hosted a guest who said
that white nationalists need to
infiltrate public schools specifically
to become teachers and spread white
nationalism and she agreed with the
guests and she said she is one of those
teachers that is doing exactly that now
I'm not gonna play any of her podcast
for you
but there are episodes available online
which you can find easily if you're
interested in that and like any good
white nationalist obviously she's
anti-semitic she loves the work of
anti-semitic author Kevin Macdonald she
has talked about the complex Jewish
Question which is a known way of
referring to the anti-semitic conspiracy
theory related to Jewish control of
media banking and politics
she has praised and defended and
retweeted neo-nazis and white
supremacists including the infamous
David Duke and she also believes and
this is so crazy because I told you last
week this was happening remember that
teacher last week in Georgia who fired a
gun in school she said that that was a
false flag conspiracy theory exactly
like I told you some lunatic conspiracy
theorists were saying really checking
all of the boxes here and we have
learned over the weekend that Dianna
vola touch has been removed from the
classroom that's the word that's being
used she's not been fired at this point
there's an investigation going on but
she has been removed
from the classroom according to the
superintendent of schools there so
obviously that's the right decision she
should be fired but this is going to
bring up questions of free speech I'm
not saying that they are warranted
questions but it is going to bring up
questions of free speech because this is
a public school and this is arguably
some will say us a government entity in
other words public schools or
government-run telling her that her
speech outside of the classroom
disqualifies her from her job which is
in a sense the government deciding what
speech is okay however I don't know that
that's the only explanation because in
the podcast she does admit that she's
teaching white nationalist views to
students in school and that's very
different because now all of a sudden
you can get rid of her because she's
teaching white nationalist values in
school so I actually don't think it's an
issue of free speech yes he I was going
to play devil's advocate and say that
all teachers have their own personal
opinion I don't personal politics yeah
especially her because she says social
studies teachers don't knows about
government and civics but as long as you
can keep that outside of the classroom
maybe there's a case we made that you
can stay on listen I am NOT a free
speech absolutist right I'm not on if
you think of a spectrum from zero to a
hundred zero being total control of
speech 100 being absolute and total free
speech I'm at like a 96 right where I
think that incitement to violence if you
go on a plane and you go that guy he's a
terrorist attack them and and that's
that's not true right that is a type of
speech that is okay to regulate because
of the implications that it has speech
regarding when you're talking about
something like child pornography and
there's a big debate about pornography
being a type of speech when it goes into
child pornography you are now talking
about age of consent you're talking
about someone it's a it's a different
scenario right it goes beyond just
speech so I am NOT a free speech
absolutist I think that I'm like a
ninety six out of a hundred on that
issue but here you do have a situation
where she is admitting that this is
becoming part of how she is teaching
children in schools and at that point it
does become an issue for the school
district and it's true if she had a
podcast about knitting you wouldn't
whether she was talking about knitting
and evangelizing about knitting to her
classroom because that's not
fundamentally at odds with the values of
the public school district this is
different and I think that we will hear
free speech complaints from some people
I don't think that they're gonna be
legitimate or hold up and the sad thing
is this could actually be beneficial for
a career because even though she may
lose the teaching job oh yeah maybe some
right-wing site will take her up and
have her podcast have a podcast on there
outlet absolutely she will be guest
hosting for Tucker Carlson for the next
three weeks I'm sure today's episode of
the David Pakman show is made possible
in part by brilliant you watch the David
Pakman show or listen to the David
Pakman show
so clearly you're interested in politics
and in following what's going on in the
world and the economy the environment
but what's crucial to understand is that
almost everything we talk about on this
show is sort of on the foundation of
math science and philosophy and keeping
up with the news is one thing but you're
never really fully equipped to
understand political issues and have
debates with people until you've
actually developed a more complete
understanding of how the world works and
how these issues work at the most
fundamental level and brilliant is one
of the most effective and enjoyable ways
to do that that I've ever come across
you can learn hands-on about statistics
crime climate science energy it's a long
list and you can get started right now
by signing up for free at brilliant org
slash David Pakman first two hundred
people who visit brilliant org slash
David Pakman will also get 20% off an
annual premium and membership check it
out sign up for free today at brilliant
org slash David Pakman